there are clues that the queen is not  seriously ill i think the fact that the  duchess of cambridge is now winding up a  really successful two-day tour in  denmark and that prince charles is now  tested negative for kovid and is back at  work you get the sense that far from  alarm bells clanging there really is no  real concern about the queen's health  the courtiers i've spoken to have used  the word cautious  the queen is in good spirits that today  from royal expert katie nichol who spoke  to palace insiders this morning another  royal headline today kate's baby fever  during her visit to denmark the mother  of three told reporters that william  gets concerned when she's around  newborns quote i come home saying let's  have another one i think if she could  she'd have a fourth  william joked about it during an outing  last month when kate held a baby girl  i think probably three is the magic  number for the cambridges but never say  never